欢迎各位说明今天这期摆车权说我是三刀。
前一段时间去到北京试驾了高山七。
当时这个车子还没有正式命名，它还叫做高山七新品。
前两天大家如果看了上次发布会已经知道了，
这个车的名字叫做高山七SUV版。
其实我也觉得很奇怪，大家肯定也觉得很奇怪。
就是一个MPV的车型，为什么要叫自己是SUV呢？
这两天我相信有些朋友如果关心过这款车，
应该也看到了一些媒体的报道，
包括试车视频，大家也陆续发布了。
就关于这个试车视频的发布我也是真的一波三折。
唐家的意思是除了去拍一个正片之外，
建议大家再拍一个切片。
什么意思呢？
就是说你可以单独拍，
你也可以在正片里面去切一个一分钟左右的一段视频。
它是希望我们媒体能够帮它的车辆的通过性就着重强调一下。
那当然了我们其实也是理解的，对吧。
所以我们当然也去，我单独就是在车子里面讲了一下这个车的通过性，
因为它是抬高了三公分嘛。
那么开的过程当中也不像抬高桥，
也不像选价抬高之后，
左右晃的这种抚养侧性比较严重。
它其实还是传统的MPV那种价实的感受，
只不过它的做资会相对偏高一点，
就那种体感会比较明显，
这我后面也会提到。
但是这个视频的发布呢，
就在传播节奏方面，
就两边跟的就不是特别的配合度不是特别高，
包括平台那边也是。
那么后来我们就一直到6月22号前后，
正片才发，
然后我们的切片也是在6月16号上市的嘛，
我们大概是在17号的样子去发布的。
那么中间我们也看到很多媒体是逼我们要早发布的，
包括有些粉丝也会问我说，
哎你看这车子都已经发了，
我记得三刀你也参加这个活动呢，
你怎么没发，
还是粉丝提醒了我，
我才知道哦原来通行媒体都在发。
所以我就觉得有的时候在这些信息同步方面，
哎真的我们挺吃亏的，
我们真挺吃亏的，
反应速度都会比北上广的一些媒体要慢一点，
或者说是可能会跟厂房的联动性会慢一点，
因为我们是吃自媒体这碗饭的，
我们当然是希望我们的内容是第一时间去发，
而有的时候就是你遵守规则，
你就是老老实实别人讲什么时间点，
什么时候去发布，
你包括签的保密鞋，
衣裳的这些时间点和实际的发布的时间点，
其实它也不完全一样，
它动不动都要变，
而变动的过程中我们总是会接受的信息慢一些，
那这我们就很吃亏了，
所以包括还有一些平台的这种先流这些事情，
太复杂了，
所以做自媒体有的时候不是讲，
我只要把内容好好的做，
我把内容认真正的给做好就结束了，
不是这样子的，
就往往你吸引鼓鼓做一个内容，
最后你发到网上去，
你要么就是平台先流，
平台被夹，
就是我们讲的就是被夹，
就是指微博那边就是把你的内容下架，
或者是限制你转发，
限制你曝光，
那前两天韩禄老师他也讲了这么一件事情吧，
对吧,
就所有的一切都是到最后那一个卡口，
就等你上线更新的时候，
就出了这样那样的问题，
我曾经也讲过，
厂家也是要给平台去交保护费的，
交什么保护费呢，
就是我的新车上市了，
那这么多媒体过来去试车，
他们肯定会去发一些内容，
大家其实也都看到了，
你比如说静态拍摄会在同一个盆子里面去拍，
对吧,
那出来的内容背景都是一样的，
那么如果是动态拍摄的话，
那动态的车辆也要停一个地方，
那停的这些地点，
一般都是厂方它会提前帮你去采点采好，
甚至包括你像之前我们去拍理想L9，
理想L9它更有意思，
它是把所有的，
比方说十几辆车，
它是固定停在某些固定的位置，
就是它的背景几乎都是一样的，
只不过你在网上去看的话，
你可能会你看十几个账号，
几十个账号它的背景都不太一样，
它实际上就是因为它十几辆车停在一个非常大的，
也是北京是在密运那边吧，
它一个这种有点像度假村一样的，
公园里面这个也是非常难找的一个地方，
不知道他们怎么找得到的，
非常大的一个公园里面，
在这个公园里面它车子就停在十几个不同的地点，
所以说这个怎么弄呢，
就是平台也知道你是，
你不是充值，
你也不是广告，
但是平台也知道你是统一的一个相当于商业市价，
所以就必须要由厂方来跟平台沟通交完保护费，
那保护费呢也很搞笑，
保护费有的是交易天的，
只管你这易天发布，
它不现流，
但是第二天之后它就开始现，
有的那保护费是交易星期的，
就是这一个星期这里不现，
但是只要过了一个星期你再发，
它平台也会判定你这个现流，
就是不让你去更新，
那么还有的就是说，
它也不跟你讲清楚是易天还是七天，
那你如果是出了问题的，
你像我们这种号比较大的，
我们是有专门定向的这种平台的联系人，
就是会拉个裙，
然后我再去通过私人的关系，
个人的关系，
它再帮我捞出来，
就我们的行话就是被现流的内容再把它给解禁，
就叫捞出来，
然后关小黑乌乌的给捞出来，
好了，我们前面就讲了一些，
就是我们遇到的一些小的问题点，
但我们还是回到这个车上来讲，
那么有些人就会觉得奇怪，
说这明明就是一辆MPV，
为什么要取个名字叫SUV呢，
其实本质上来讲，
它就是高山7的这个车型，
它增加了一个配置，
那么原来的这个高山7它也在寿，
这个高山7SUV它主要就是三个变化点，
第一个就是它底盘抬高了三公分，
从原来的155毫米的这个离力渐吸，
现在是提升到了185毫米，
那么可能大家对这个没什么概念，
就是正常的SUV车型，
不，应该叫MPV，
MPV车型它的离力渐吸在160毫米上下，
就稍微好一点的可能165，
正常就是155-160，
上下一点点，
那么这次抬高了30毫米嘛，
相当于就是185，
那么这是第一点，
第二点就是它加了裂装套件，
其实这个裂装套件不是特别的明显，
就是除非你对于原来的高山7你比较了解，
你比方说它侧面的这个下裙边这个位置。
有杜格式条，
比方说前面还有维保杠这个位置，
你就很仔细的去看，
你就知道了新款跟之前的这个标准版之间是有区别的，
加了个裂装套件，
那么裂装套件加上去之后呢，
它的车身长度也会有变化，
包括宽度也会有变化，
所以一开始有些媒体解读说这个车它是加长版，
我先讲一遍，
它不是加长版，
我要解释清楚，
轴距是一模一样的，
它只是因为加了个套件，
所以宽度和长度都会有一些变化，
那么第三个呢就是多了个四驱模式，
有人讲说不对啊，
这个车本身不就是High-Four嘛，
它全系都是四驱嘛，
是这样子的，
但是它多了这个四驱模式，
是在它的系统里面可以选择的，
那么一会我再讲，
就是它为什么要去强调这个四驱模式，
实际上它本身原来的版本，
它也是有四驱有High-Four的，
那么增加了这么一个高尚器SUV的版本，
它的指导价跟原来还是一样的，
指导价都是285800，
然后现在的现实优惠价是2780800，
实际上它的原来的版本也是一样的，
也是有这个优惠的，
什么意思呢，
就是说它这个15000块钱的优惠是用5000去抵8000，
那不就是减了3000吗，
然后再给你一个增换购的1200的补贴，
那么有人说这个1200的补贴也不是什么人都能拿啊，
那我没有增购也没有换购，
那我怎么拿呢，
其实这个东西嘛，
懂得都懂啊，
既然都给你说出来了嘛，
那一定是有的嘛，
对不对，
就你只要提供一个行驶认什么的，
就是大家都懂，
就你哪怕你没有，
销售也只要想卖你这个车，
是一定能帮你搞得定的，
就说明这个厂家审核放的是比较宽的，
就为了促进销量嘛，
对吧,
那么实际上这个车呢，
我们当时我去北京拿到手的时候，
就是我刚开始拿到这个车，
我一坐上去，
我的感觉就是这个车重心比较高，
就是我坐上去的感觉重心比较高，
就是你仔细在车外去看这个车子，
抬高三公分，
其实不是那么的明显，
你比如说我当时拍摄的就是建西中午12点左右，
我们当时想去吃个饭，
我把这个车开到旁边，
我搜了一下一个叫南门涮热，
也是非常不错的一家店，
我跟我的摄像师准备去吃个南门涮热，
然后呢我就把车停在停车场，
停车场的旁边正好就是这个藤石地久，
然后旁边还有一辆是什么车，
我忘了，
然后我就把这两台车停在一起，
我就仔细看它的离地建西，
就是按道理讲它抬高三公分，
肯定是要比旁边的MPV要高一些的嘛，
然后侧面还有一辆SUV，
我当时就在那个车底这个位置把镜头放的很低，
我就拍了一张照片，
你从外观上来看的话，
你单看这个车的离地建西其实没有那么明显的抬高，
真的没有那么明显，
但是在座子上，
就是你只要一上车一坐，
你就会有一种高座子的感觉，
这个跟之前你不管是坐高山7，
高山8还是高山9，
它是完全不一样的，
高座子高中心的感觉，
那么人坐在这种比较偏高座子的车子里面，
会有一种什么样的感受呢，
就是你会明显会想把这个车的车速放慢，
这是怎么讲的条件反射吧，
人坐在一个项目比较高的这种状态下，
你不会开太快的车，
不会开快车，
那么很多人也会担心，
就是说这种高座子高中心，
它车子开起来会不会发飘啊，
会不会像在踩高桥啊，
那一会动态驾驶我再来跟大家讲，
但是整体来讲这个车呢，
就是高山7的SUV它加的套件，
在视觉上来看的话，
这个车会显得更硬一些，更宽一些，
更有一点点的跨界的味道，
车长是变成了5050，
因为加长了嘛，
那么宽度也是比以前要再会稍微宽一点，
那么轴距还是一样的，
都是3085,
只不过加列装的包围，
好,
那我们来讲一讲这个车的这个四驱模式，
它为什么要强调这一点啊，
这个四驱模式呢，
我们知道普通版本也是High-Four四驱，
它强调这个，
其实更像是它针对非浦装路面，
我们讲就是那种什么烂路啊，
石子路啊，
包括湿滑路面，
湿滑就下雨下雪啊，
你包括轻度的一些脱困的场景，
那你能说以前的版本没有优化吗，
也不一定，
但是它现在把它单独拎出来，
就是在你的驾驶模式里面，
单独有一个四驱模式，
它就强调，
我是做了场景优化的，
这个车子是介于MPV跟SUV之间的，
遇到一些什么勾勾侃侃的，
你不要害怕，
以前有可能会蹭底盘的，
现在太高三公分也许它就不蹭了，
而且包括车身的整体的这种底盘韧性啊，
就是,
因为我们知道车子不仅仅离地间隙要高，
如果它旋挂调得非常软，
你车上坐的人又很多，
你速度稍微再快一点，
来回弹，
它有的时候不是说慢速的蹭底盘，
是你速度稍微快一点，
上下起伏的时候它会蹭啊，
我们知道以前很多人开天赖，
对吧,
开天赖它就不敢走烂路啊，
为什么，
因为天赖的悬架它整个的行程，
压缩的相对来讲会行程比较长，
有的时候我记得我从，
我从那个时候上班是从江陵，
然后开车回家，
我开车回家的时候我是坐在雨花嘛，
我要走一段，
龙村的相接那条路，
穿过去就会更近一点，
然后我经常下班会遇到一个天赖，
那个人估计也是跟我同一时间一点下班，
他在我的前面开，我在后面开，
我那时候要开个小澳拓嘛，
我就跟在他后面，
我澳拓本身就跟开卡丁车一样，
就是说我的这个视线会比较的低，
我就看着那个天赖，
每次一过坑蹭一下，
一过坑蹭一下，
我就十分担心他的那个，
宝杠给蹭坏了，
或者那个底盘位蹭开了，
然后那哥们本身开的也比较猛，
对吧,
我一个小澳拓在后面，
他好像感觉就特别想把我给甩掉，
但是我当时开澳拓开的也比较猛，
虽然我只有四个挡，
我只有三缸，
但是我开的速度也不慢，
我就一直跟在他后面，
他就想把我甩掉，
他速度就会比较开，
每次他一过坑蹭一下，
一过坑蹭一下，
我就感觉我的澳拓好像，
离地间隙都比他高，
因为我也不担心，
我蹭也无所谓对吧，
所以我就讲他不仅仅是离地间隙这一点，
包括这个车辆的，
你像有些SUV车型，
他还讲就接近脚，离去脚，
对吧,
包括他的整个的车身结构，
还有轮胎的抓力力，
他是各方面都要综合考虑的，
那高山级SUV，
他毕竟只是一个MPV车型，
他只不过想要具备一定的SUV的属性，
他也可能是个营销的概念，
太高三公分就一定能解决吗？
他也不一定能解决，
对吧,
他只是说解决你敢不敢走的问题，
而不是你能不能豁车，
豁出去的这个问题点，
所以他不是越野车，
也不是SUV，
所以这一点我一定要给大家强调，
虽然说他的营销命名上来是带了一个SUV，
这样那个单词啊，
那么网上很多人还是说这个车他看不懂，
就是长城为什么要出一个高山级SUV，
感觉有点不伦不累的，
就是真想买SUV的人不会因为他的离地间器。
从155提升到185毫米就觉得够用了，
真想买MPV的人也不会因为他多了一套。
裂装到这个风格的套件，
就无脑去下单，
这个话我觉得说的没有错，
但是长城他这一招我觉得玩的是。
怎么理解呢，
就是说他在利用这个产品做品牌敘事，
他想给高山这个系列找一个新制入口，
你这样的想啊，
长城最强的一个标签是什么，
其实我觉得是SUV，
对不对，
长城是没有轿车的，
长城一直是打造自己的SUV这样的一个标签，
你不管是之前的哈佛，
哈佛就不用做了嘛，
哈佛H6对吧，
包括坦克，
坦克300一战成名，
是不是大家对于，
你包括了V牌，
V牌也有啊，
V牌蓝山，
蓝山之前卖的挺好的，
所以他的整个的长城这个品牌，
他的标签，
他就是SUV最有名，
那么长城是一个会造SUV的品牌，
对吧,
他的四区也挺强的，
之前哈佛H9对吧，
也是在国内的SUV里面，
在硬派的SUV里面，
也是非常有名气的，
坦克300就更不用说了嘛，
坦克500其实卖的也挺好的，
就一系列的这样的车型，
那么他会造SUV，
会玩四区，
他的车子能跑烂路，
这些都是他很值钱的一个标签，
但是问题是什么，
问题是高山他试一台MPV，
而且你再想一想，
长城他本身在做新能源的时候，
就用了High-Four这个概念，
就是他们家的新能源都是四区，
那么他现在进入到MPV这个市场，
进来就是四区，
就我没有两区车，
我全是四区，
那么面对像G2吧，
塞纳这种都是传统选手，
在面对像藤氏第九，
南投梦想家，
这个就属于国家新能源的这些对手了，
那么长城在这个领域里面，
他有没有天然的优势呢，
似乎是有那么一点，
就从产品力上来讲没什么问题，
但是你看，
南投梦想家藤氏第九，
哪个不能打，
个个都很能打，
是不是，
你包括G2吧出了混动之后，
塞纳天生就是风田的日系混动，
就每一个都有自己的特长，
每个都是很角色，
那么他怎么去打，
虽然讲目前来看，
就是高山啊，
就是他整个系列啊，
高山七八九，
加在一起一个月销量五六千台，
有人说也不是很多，
也不是很多吗，
MPV一个月五六千台已经是，
稳居销量排行榜前三名了，
你不能指望一个MPV一个月卖一两万啊，
这太夸张了，
对吧五六千已经是前三名了，
再往上抬一抬就是前二，
如果真的是能接近一万台，
一万上下，
那基本上就是能到第一名上去了，
所以长辰他其实野心，
他不是说我要排个第三，
我不是想当老三也不想当老二，
他甚至想当老大，
那有人讲说你一个，
这个长辰造MPV，
我都没什么概念的这么一个品牌，
你现在想当老大，
你凭什么当老大呢，
你长辰有这个基因吗，
哎你要如果提到基因啊，
那我觉得这个话题就有得了了，
其实他现在就是在告诉用户，
就你买的不是一台传统的商务MPV，
而是一台有长辰SUV基因的MPV，
所以我说他是阳谋，
那么有人要问了说，
哦你把底盘抬高一点，
你就是SUV了，
那你这互用谁呢，
对不对抬高底盘很难吗，
那别家为什么不能抬高底盘呢，
我跟你这么讲，
你想一想，
为什么别家的MPV卖了那么多年，
就没有人想过说，
哎我能不能去抬高底盘吗，
对吧,
我把离地线系抬高一点，
很多的一些买MPV的人是不是会讲过这么一句话，
或者说没买的人啊，
他会说这个MPV好事挺好的，
但是我就是担心蹭底盘，
我就是看到这个MPV啊，
他这个离地线系太低了，
离地线系低呢也有好处，
你比如说上下车门的时候会比较的方便，
家里面有老人有孩子，
很多MPV侧面不是有那个上车的门把手吗，
对不对，
上车的那个扶手吗，
就拉一下，
小孩子可以拉下面，
老人可以拉上面，
那个门上的拉手一般都很长的，
中间分两段的，
对不对，
这个是很方便的，
就是考虑到这些老人孩子能上车吗，
很方便，
那么别家为什么不去干呢，
传统的MPV为什么不去，
也出一个类似于这种抬高底盘的版本吗，
G-28賽纳那些车，
你想一想，
它诞生之初就是低门槛低地台，
它要保证它的舒适性，
要给人感觉这个车子看上去比较的低趴，
稳重,
商务借贷，
车的整体的气场很修长很优雅，
它们的产品逻辑不是说，
它要往车子高重心高底盘的方向去做，
它不是往这方面去做，
是要做的相对低趴一点，
而且它主打的就是在城区里面，
在高速上去进行行驶，
之前我看G-28PHEV的版本上市的时候，
官方有一页PPT就是这么讲的，
因为它当时是做的小电池包大邮箱，
它说我为什么要做小电池包大邮箱，
因为它当时去做后台的统计，
就是70%-80%的路况，
MPV都是在高速上行驶，
就是很多的MPV就是一拿到手，
长期跑高速，
所以它的公里数会追上多，
有的MPV一年开三四万公里，
甚至更多，
有的时候甚至于驾驶员休息，
车子不休息，
驾驶员休息就是轮班嘛，
就这个车子在公司里面，
今天你不开了明天它开，
或者今天你不开，
紧跟着第二个司机上，
轮班轮着去开这个车出差，
所以当时别客的意思就是说，
我邮箱给你配大一点，
因为高速公路上面用纯油去行驶，
反而它的这个功况会更好一点，
它的这个能耗会更好一些，
但是呢就很多人不认啊，
为什么呢，
因为你既然是性能源MPV，
那你肯定是要去对标它的纯电续航，
因为我平时日常在市区逮捕的时候，
我要用纯电啊，
你用那么大的邮箱有什么用啊，
我长期都不用邮，
所以这就是个悖论，
所以你看后来不是，
这个G28的混沌版本也是把它的这个电池加大了嘛，
纯电续航也加长了嘛，没办法，
对吧没办法，
你工程师的逻辑，
你想的再好再透彻，
你哪怕是用它的数据算法去算啊，
MPV长期都在高速上没有用，
就是市场上的消费者就认它的纯电续航一定要长，
电池包一定要大，
那你怎么办呢，
你只能跟着这个市场上去折啊，
要不然你销量上不去嘛，
对不对，
所以你看以前的MPV都是往低趴上去做，
都是往低姿态上去做，
那么MPV为什么舒服啊，
就是因为它门槛低嘛，
上下车也方便嘛，
看起来很稳吧，
对吧老人孩子上车不费劲，
车子开起来也会更加的这个稳定，
那么这个车子本身就卖的很好，
就我想以前的赛辣鸡儿吧，
它就是哪怕离地渐息低，
它卖的也很好，
你现在说啊，
就因为有一部分人讲啊，
底盘低了，
你要是抬高一点我就买，
好,
工程师花了大价钱，
花了很多的精力，
去把它底盘抬高，
就不是说抬高那个三公分就三公分的，
它要做底盘键的加强，
然后要做整个的整全车的这个底盘调，
对不对，
要整个的底盘甚至全部都得重新设计，
这个工程量是巨大的，
要花很多的人力物力啊，
那么最后可能是吃力不讨好，
出了这么一个版本，
老用户觉得你反而不正宗了，
新用户又觉得我看不懂你这设计，
你这什么意思啊，
你这还是MPV吗，
你这是不是有点不伦不累的三不像啊，
好了,
到最后喊的这个护身非常高的那些人也不买，
老用户原本就想买MPV的人，
又觉得说你这怎么回事，
他也不会买，
所以说肯定这些传统的MPV的车商，
他是不会去干这个事的，
这些车企不会干的，
但是位牌它不一样，
它本来就是一个追赶者，
它原来就没造过MPV，
它是干嘛呢，
它是来抢蛋糕的，
它是来打雷台的，
它不是手雷的，
所以呢这个后发的一些车型，
有后发的优势也有后发的劣势，
劣势是什么呢，
就是说因为我后发了嘛，
那么之前的市场已经给你刮分掉了，
MPV等于G28,。
G28等于MPV,。
你已经占领了消费者的薪质，
对不对，
商用买G28，
家用买Sina，
对不对，
那这些车子本身也是经过这么多年的验证，
也没什么毛病，
也很稳定，
实用性各方面都没问题，
那么我有个二二多万，
我该买G28的路上公务仓，
还是说有个三二多万去买路尊，
或者去买这个Sina，
那我其实就已经被这两个品牌就刮分掉了，
那么现在我为什么还要去买你一个后来者高山呢，
我凭什么要买高山，
高山有什么优势呢，
那么后发的车型也有后发的优势点，
就是后发车型它没什么历史包袱，
也就是说对位牌来讲，
反正我在MPV市场上我也没有给自己什么定义，
我也没有什么太高的知名度，
也就才上市一年才两年，
那么我去学之前的G28，
学Sina,
你的前脸造的那个样子，
我也跟着你学前脸的造型，
你的车上有什么配置，
我就比你配置再多一点，
然后你的整个车的内饰设计是什么样，
我也是什么样，
你永远跟在后面学，
那你销量永远超不过它，
那不如我直接就开一条新路，
我开一条岔路，
我赌一把，
我觉得老魏这个人是赌信蛮重的，
就是你们负责把MPV做的更商务更舒适，
那我呢，
我把MPV做的更加的偏户外一点，
更适合全场景，
哪怕你说有点像跨界也可以，
跨界在MPV里面我觉得不是坏事，
为什么呢，
因为很多人觉得MPV它太像一个工具车了，
像工具车呢，
我就更像是个司机，
而如果我把MPV做的稍微的偏跨界一点，
这个车是不是就有点意思了，
就不太像是工具车，
不太像是司机了，
我举个例子，
很多人一直在骂那个Mega，
这个Mega怎么怎么丑，
怎么价格怎么怎么不合理，
甚至还用网上的那种，
就怎么讲呢，
我觉得都有点造谣的那种言论啊，
说有点像那什么车，
那你看真正我身边买Mega的人，
首先它是绝对高进值用户，
那当然了，
因为这个车的车价本身也不便宜，
而且这连头能花那么多的钱去买一个纯电MPV的，
绝对是家里面BPA已经不知道玩了多少年都不想玩了那些人，
但是你要知道第二点是什么，
就是买Mega的几乎没有什么网约车司机，
或者说几乎没有哪个公司的老板说买这个车当公司的商务用车很少，
一般买Mega的，
那当然了能买这个车的人很多自己，
他就是开公司的，
他也可以拿这个车去高铁站去机场去接用户，
但是平时这个车子更多就日常带个户，
然后日常就是老婆去接接孩子，
或者是父母拿着车去接接孩子，
就是家用带那么一丢丢的商用，
所以没有人会说我买个Mega，
我觉得这台车子更像工具车，
我开出去更像是个司机，
那就算是个司机又怎样，
对吧,
你在一个能开六七十万的老板公司里面打个工，
那这个司机也是号称这公司二把手啊，
对不对，
我觉得无所谓啊，
那么好，
现在高山出了一个叫高山汽SUV，
那怎么地，
你敢跟着我一起叫这个名字吗？
你不敢呀，
如果你后面觉得说高山汽SUV卖的还不错，
那咱们也抬高底盘，
也叫什么什么SUV，
SinaSUV,。
G28SUV,
或者是藤石第九SUV，
你如果这么叫的话，
你告诉我这个圈子里面谁是第一个叫的，
那就是高山啊，
好那开心啊，
老魏肯定开心都睡不着觉了，
你们都在模仿我，
你们都在模仿我说明什么，
说明我很成功啊，
我是有先见之明的，
对不对，
同行模仿，
同行吹捧，
这是最受用的，
他得抬高你嘛，
对不对，
所以说，
这一招相当于是堵死别人的后路嘛，
那么对于位牌来说，
他做对了就是增量，
就是在现有的基础上能够增加小量扩大影响力，
增加自己的核心精灵力，
那么如果说做错了，
大家都不买单，
什么SUV啊，
你就是个MPV，
抬高三公分底盘就是SUV了吗？
不卖不卖不卖，
我都是买正常版本，
我就不买这个版本，
没关系啊，
如果真卖不动，
过个一两年就停掉呗，
它不就是停了一个page而已嘛，
这又无所谓的了，
反正常规版本该卖还是正常卖，
对它没有丝毫的影响，
所以为什么我说它是个阳谋呢？
那么把高山的系列SUV化，
这件事情还有一个地方，
我觉得也蛮厉害的，
就是它不是这一个车型，
7,8,9,
它是一条产品线，
它这一条产品线，
先用7来做个试探，
7是它最入门的版本嘛，
8是它们家的这个销量担当，
是卖的最好的，
那么9是它们家的旗舰，
那你要知道8跟9都是最早上的，
7是后上的，
结果7反而是先增加那个版本，
那为什么呢，很简单啊，
先在入门里面试试水，
入门本身销量不是最大的，
那么入门的版本我试个水，
如果能把入门的原本销量不大的这个版本，
通过增加了一个SUV版，
销量结果反而变得更好了，
甚至超过了这个高山8，
那就说明这个实验是成功的，
这个试水是成功的，
那我就继续让高山8也出个SUV，
再试一试，
如果没有问题，
我再出个高山9SUV，
它是产品线的试探，
看看这个概念有没有人买单，
那么这样一来的话，
你想想看，
如果说啊，
如果说它把这些什么高山7，
高山8，高山9，
再去出各自的SUV版，
位牌相当于在25到35万这个区间，
它除了有MPV的这个传统的这样的三款车型去打市场，
它是不是又多了一组，
又多了一组，
就是MPV版的高山789，
那么相当于就是跨界牌，
它拿到这个跨界牌就打谁呢，
它就不是去打MPV了，
它相当于就去蹭那些中大型SUV和大型SUV的流量池了，
去抢那些用户了，
那抢的是谁呢，
那都不用说了嘛，
那就是隔壁的理想，问戒，
未来,
这些这些产品嘛，
包括什么比亚迪呀，
吉利的这些大车，
是不是这些大型SUV，
中大型SUV，
所以这一次在媒体试驾的时候，
我也看到厂方在这个宣传的brief里面也在讲说，
希望媒体老师们能不能去说一说，
就这个车型去跟理想的L8、L9去对比呀，
去跟问戒的M7、M8、M9这些车型去对比呀，
那我当时看到这个，
我在想，
这MPV跟SUV对比，
这是抢的哪一出呢，
但是我再想一想，
它为什么这个名字命名要加SUV呢，
当时瞬间我就想明白这个道理了，
对吧,
这个市场说白了，
你MPV原来就是跟MPV打，
但是我出这个，
我去抢SUV市场，
你开玩笑SUV市场是MPV市场的多少倍呀，
那个蛋糕可比这个蛋糕要大得多得多啊，
MPV市场的蛋糕最多也就是，
相当于是个小甜点，
到那个蛋糕店里面去买的话，
就是在那个小冰柜里面的那个小甜点，
那这个蛋糕那是这28年的生日蛋糕啊，
这个大小相当于就是，
那不是一层了，
那可能是九层塔，
可能是七层三层六层，
对吧,
那种就是到香冰酒的那种蛋糕了，
那它就非常大的，
蛋糕大了，
矛盾就小嘛，
对不对，
MPV如果说真的能切中了SUV市场，
稍微滑波一点销量过来，
那都是我估计都能翻倍增长，
非常夸张的，
但是有人可能会讲了，
说哎呀三刀你多小了，
MPV就是MPV,。
虽然讲说价格段，
是从好比讲25万到35万这个区间，
但是你说拿这个MPV车型，
去跟25到35万的SUV去做对比，
你怎么比啊，
你怎么去比SUV的25到35万可选的车可多了，
他们俩的用户是不可能重叠的，
兄弟你确定不可能重叠吗，
你确定吗，
我跟你说我身边已经有人是拿，
这个不一定是高山啊，
已经是拿新能源的MPV，
去和新能源的SUV去做对比了，
而且不止是一个两个，
我不不能说很多，
但是我真的经常我在回答问题的时候是能遇到的，
真不一定，
就是不一定他们不重叠，
是有重叠的，
理想L789高山这个789，
它都是一栋客厅啊，
那么现在长城如果把高山SUV，
这样的一个新制成功植入到用户的心里面去，
那后面这个销量增长还真不好说，
因为之前没人这么玩过，
不知道这条路到底往后走，
顺还是不顺啊，
事实上买不买单，
因为你想现在SUV是越做越大，
即使是做到像L9那么大，
或者是像WIN界M9那么大，
车上超过5米2，
轴距差不多在3米1出头一点，
3米1上下，
但是你要知道SUV车型，
它基于造型的这个原因啊，
它是要讲究时尚感，
讲究流线性的，
那么它即使是做到大型SUV，
第三排的空间，
包括头部空间，
还有两侧的，
很像纵向这些空间，
也不一定能比得上中大型MPV，
对不对，
中大型MPV我们讲，
就是传统来讲，
这是SANA,
或者像G28这种，
包括我们看到的藤室，
梦想家其实为什么卖的好，
梦想家更大一点，
它虽然也是定位中大型MPV，
它在这个级别里面来讲，
它的尺寸会更大一些，
那么包括今天我们聊的高山，
高山其实很多人眼中，
高山8为什么卖的好，
就是它的整体的尺寸，
包括造型的协调性，
气场各方面，
也是符合大家对于这个级别，
这个价位30多万的MPV的一个理解，
所以MPV的造型，
看上去虽然说，
稍微有点丑，
有点像这种小面包车，工具车，
但是它造型它方方正正的，
它能装啊，
这个装不是那个装插的装啊，
这是真的能装啊，
装人装东西，
头部空间，横向的空间，
纵向的空间，
它的车内不管是前排中间的这个两个位置，
还是后排，
它整个三排照顾的都会比SUV更好，
所以现在很多买新单元MPV的用户，
你想一想，
它已经不在乎什么品牌物品牌了，
对吧,
然后质价现在大家基本上，
我不敢说说这个完全一样吧，
基本是一条水平线上了，
只不过像华为一样小棚可能略好一点，
其他家还在追赶，
还在需要通过OTA不停的去优化，
但硬件层面上来讲，
其实大家差距也不是特别大了，
对不对，
那么还有什么东西呢，
车上的什么冰箱，
彩电，大沙发，
那该有的都有了，
系统优化这么多年，
其实大家也都差不多，
我们讲叫车内的，
包括只能车机啊，
对吧,
什么只能座舱这些东西，
那么大家也不太在乎，
就是什么这个车子还是偏商务一点，
还是说这个车子偏家用一点，
还是像司机，
就你只要功能配置足够多，
这些东西其实都不重要，
以前为什么传统的MPV，
大家觉得说像司机啊，
太商务啊，
或者像网约车啊，
是因为以前在传统的MPV里面，
它是把这个也不能叫阶层吧，
就是它是把这个产品的层级定的是非常明确的，
就是你路上公务舱，
你就只配开路上公务舱的这一切配置，
啊就不要说没有天窗也好，
或者是置物座椅也好，
这个没有大屏也好，
你就只能听收音机啊，
我讲的有点夸张了，
就是大家能理解我的意思啊，
就是你路上公务舱就是路上公务舱这个层级，
你是不能越越急的，
那么你到了路尊，
你路尊就只能享受路尊这一部分东西，
装黄装修啊这些东西，
你只能是到这个级别，
你在网上那个时候还有艾维亚嘛，
你到了艾维亚，
我就随车还能赠送你脱鞋，
还能赠送你这个矛毯，
啊就更尊贵了，
但是你想一个MPV，
那你为什么要搞那么多的层级呢，
你搞那么多层级就是因为啊这个是老板开的，
啊那个是司机开的，
啊这个是网约车司机开的，
那个是公司司机开，
就我觉得也不是那么没这个必要，
我觉得不是不是这样的一种打法就能吃的透市场的，
在当年任，
但是在现在这个年代新能源MPV里面，
很多人是不认的，
因为新能源MPV它讲的是平权嘛，
好它讲的平权那你怎么去做差异化呢，
你上来就是满配也不行啊，
对不对你上来就满配也不行，
所以长城这个玩法是对的，
就是我是只有一个配置，
但是我把这一个配置分配在不同的这个体量的车型里面，
诶之前没人这么玩过，
什么叫不同体量呢，
我有高山7，
我有高山8，
我有高山9，
车身的长框高尺寸不一样，
就是整个车给人的体量感啊，
包括这种气场也不一样，
就你根据自己的需求来买就行了，
你不要去看配置，
配置都一样，
对吧你就看它这个体量感，
气场啊包括空间大小，
你有什么需求你就去选吧，
所以这个玩法之前是没有的，
那么现在呢台高三公分之后，
高山7SUV这个版本，
它就卡在了SUV跟MPV之间，
就按照这个营销的理念上来讲是卡在这个中间啊，
那空间是比SUV要强对不对，
姿态呢比MPV还要再稍微野一点，
四驱和离地间西又比传统MPV要更加有那么一点安全感，
反正呢就是能抢一部分SUV用户我就抢一部分，
抢到了我就赚到了，
抢不到我也不亏，
因为它本来就是高山7的一个衍生版本嘛，
对不对你顺手也就是吧，
高山它也有SUV这样的一个基因，
把长城的SUV的基因也就是植入到，
或者是讲述到了这个品牌叙事里面去，
所以我觉得它就是一时三秒，
这个方法非常的聪明，
我也不知道是哪个高管提出这么一个方案啊，
我觉得真的是很聪明，
那么位牌和MPV的关联度本身就不是特别高，
刚上市的时候网上的这个争议也非常的大，
所以长城到今天为止一直在想一切办法，
就是把位牌、高山跟MPV这个关键词能够强绑定、强捆绑，
你要知道MPV其实是一个高利润的产品啊，
长城是一直想把这个利润给它提上去，
而且现在这个打价格战说实话，
谁都是希望自己家的这个单品的利润能够更高一点，
所以它这种像长城把利润看得比什么都重要的企业，
它不可能就不去想在MPV这方面去做文章的，
它能挣到钱啊，
但是隔壁呢有一个有商的品牌，
他遇到的问题呢，
恰巧与长城的这个问题相反，
它这个品牌就是跟MPV绑定的太深了，
所以导致他们家其他的车型就怎么也走不定用户的心智，
这个品牌是什么呢，
大家猜一猜，
我估计有人应该能猜得到啊，
就是藤氏，
对的比亚迪的藤氏，
藤氏这个品牌啊，
它早期的存在感并不强，
因为大家都知道一开始是跟奔驰合作，
是放在奔驰的店里面去卖的对吧，
戴布勒、戴布勒、藤氏，
但是呢，
很多人对他的认知一直都比较的模糊，
就是藤氏到底代表的是什么，
他到底定位的是什么样的人群，
他们家的车到底是卖了多少弯的车，
他都不知道，
就是真正把藤氏品牌收归到比亚迪之后，
把这个品牌给打出去，
让大家认可，
其实就是藤氏第九这款车，
藤氏第九发布的时间，
可以说是非常的完美，
他刚好是比亚迪DMI全网火爆的时候，
刚好又是新能源MPV爆发的一个窗口期，
就那个时候大家都去往新能源MPV上去看了，
因为那个时候很多老板其实也不想去开这种，
价格又贵配置又低，
开出去又像司机的传统的游车了，
那么这个时间点，
出了这么一个藤氏第九，
你不管怎么去对比，
在空间舒适度、
节能经济、商务阶段家庭出行，
你哪怕就是包括时尚感和新鲜感上面来讲的话，
那大家都认，
所以那两年可以讲，
藤氏第九把MPV转型的这个红利，
就是一家全吃完了，
就吃的是盆满薄满，
吃的是满嘴流油啊，
大家想一想是不是这么概念，
那么藤氏第九可以说一战成名，
它是以一己之力把藤氏这个品牌给托举起来了，
出圈了嘛，
大家都知道藤氏了，
都知道藤氏第九了，
但是你要想一想，
大家不是因为认可藤氏，
才去看的第九，
而是先认可了第九，
才走进了藤氏的展厅，
是不是这个概念，
是这个概念吗？
好,
那么正因为藤氏第九太成功了，
成功到他把整个藤氏这个品牌，
重新在消费者心里面去定义了一遍，
就我们刚刚讲的嘛，
就是藤氏等于第九，
第九等于藤氏，
或者说藤氏它什么最出名，
MPV最出名，
哪个MPV,
藤氏第九，
那么以前大家不知道藤氏是谁，
藤氏是什么品牌，
什么定位，
那么后来一提到藤氏，
第一反应就是这个MPV车型嘛，
藤氏第九，
所以它就代表着新能源MPV，
就这个品牌和新能源MPV，
它是强绑定的，
就是商务接待，
家庭出行，
奶爸的属性，
舒适大空间，
这些标签全部贴上去了，
那么当然了，
这些标签其实贴上去，
这个牌子也很值钱嘛，
对吧，是好事，
但是你要知道，
它原来存在感不强，
现在存在感一下子变得那么强，
那么标签一下子变得那么清晰，
那么既能成就这个品牌，
也会限制这个品牌，
是不是，
这里面我们也插句题外话，
藤氏第九当时一举成名，
其实也带动了一个人，
这个人就是当时藤氏这个项目，
藤氏第九这个项目的，
老大叫赵长江，
那么赵长江这个原来比亚迪的高管，
藤氏第九的亲爹，
现在是去到了智界，
我们知道智界最近出了一个MPV车型叫智界V9，
那么智界V9的发布会，
大家可以去回看一下，
智界V9的产品负责人，
在智界V9的发布会上，
一秒钟一分钟都没有在台上讲一句话，
全程是坐在台下，
你不觉得这个场面很奇怪吗，
这个产品线都是他来主导，
他来去带队去做的，
他是负责协调华为和齐睿之间的关系的，
但是在台上一句话没讲，
然后整场发布会也没有那些什么花里胡哨的，
什么跳舞唱歌什么的，
就是齐睿的影童乐，
华为的余晨东，
两个人各自讲各自的这一部分的内容，
然后整场发布会一个多小时就讲完了，
然后媒体镜头也会是时不时的扫过第一排，
也能拍到赵长江，
所以这叫什么呢，
这叫做再场性缺席，
就是他明明到了，
在重要场合里面他却没有发挥重要的作用，
他明明就是一个重要的人物，
但是没有站在一个合适的位置上面，
为什么会这样，很简单，
因为我觉得致介内部可能对于致介品牌目前也没什么信心，
所以他需要余晨东出来，
余晨东是什么，
他代表着华为的品牌和声量，
那么也需要影童乐出来，
影童乐代表着什么，
代表着国民品牌，
对吧,
咱们国内的自主品牌，
中国人应该叫做汽车制造业的极梁鼓，
所以影童乐的名气也很大，
那么余晨东的名气也很大，
他们两个共同为致介去背书，
然后赵长江本身他也是一个车系高管网红，
在比亚迪那个时代他就开了微博，
然后就跟网友去进行互动，
平时也去更新自己的一些动态，
所以有些人也蛮粉他的，
就会看到致介的发布会本来想等他上台讲话嘛，
就一直看他不上台不上台，
不知道发生什么事情了，
然后就问他，
那么赵总也没有去解释，
就说了一句，
哎呀刚忙完，
刚忙完确实很忙，
他要忙什么呢，
他要忙两家之间的来回协调，
这个华为是灵魂，
然后齐瑞是落地执行方，
那这两边必须要有一个人来协调，
他跟以前在比亚迪，
在腾事干的事情也不完全一样，
有人讲说他其实把腾事地久当时成功经验。
直接移植过来不就行了嘛，
可以这么说但是很难，
为什么呢，
因为原来腾事相当于只有一个亲爹，
就是王传福，
就是比亚迪集团，
那么你想想看整个集团是集团之力去托举，
腾事这个品牌，
那么因此那任何的事情在赵上江他去想推进的时候，
是没有什么阻力的，
他所不管要人还是要资源，
他所有想要的一些需求，
那都是上面直接发话就能往前推进的，
但是到了现在的，
就是到了致敬这个品牌，
那可就不一定了，
对不对，
那左边华为是希望能够更加的去，
体现自己在这个品牌里的一些想法，
然后呢齐睿他作为制造方落地方，
他也有自己的一些想法，
那他肯定是两边要去均衡啊，
所以这个事情在往后推，
这个怎么去推进呢对吧，
你包括落地之后这个产能怎么去保证呢，
据说现在订单还不错，
而且买了很多都是顶配啊，
那么那么多人去买顶配到底认的是什么，
是认直接这个牌子吗，
还是去认这个华为的灵魂，
华为的这些技术呢，
如果只认华为的技术，
并没有去认可直接这个品牌，
那我觉得可能赵总在这个位置上干的时间不一定能很久，
但是如果说他能把这个品牌，
他的存在感做得更强势，
将来大家是认一提到这个车，
哦这是致戒，
那我知道致戒是造什么车什么车的，
哦致戒就能跟另外一些什么关联词能够绑定上，
那他就很成功，
所以说他不是具备华为的那些科技负能的一个，
怎么讲呢这么讲一个电子消费品，
或者说这样的一个移动的出行的产品，
如果他不是这个而是一个致戒的一个高端的品牌，
他是能够有溢价的，
能够承托四五十万三四十万的这样一个价值感，
那他就成功了，
所以我们讲个题外话啊，
就是很有意思，
就原来是腾世的这个负责人，
现在去到了致戒去打造V9这样一个产品，
那么我们接着往下聊，
前面呢腾世D9名声在外，
后面腾世再推一些像什么Z9 GT啊，
腾世N9啊，
腾世的N8L这些车，
大家都会觉得好像怪怪的，
但是怪在哪说不上来，
其实不是说这些车不好啊，
不是说这些车不好，
只是消费者心里面会有一个下意识的疑问，
就是腾世，
腾世不是坐这个奶爸车，
新的UNPV嘛，
就是感觉这个牌子听起来就是那种软软糯糯的，
就是开起来应该是输出夫夫的那种感觉，
他怎么开始坐这种，
就是比方坐底盘悬压帮帮硬的啊，
就是感觉车子很运动啊，
怎么开始坐这种什么GT了，
开始坐大型SUV，
开始讲运动，讲豪华，讲操控，讲安全，讲性能了，
所以我说腾世遇到的问题点，
它跟长城啊，
它是恰恰相反的，
就是品牌基因它带来一个惯性，
腾世已经是跟新的UNPV它是强绑定了，
但是胃牌呢，
它没有强绑定，
它既有之前的像蓝山啊，
大家知道蓝山也是。
胃牌转型的一个非常重要的作品，
那么后来又出了像高山啊，
那胃牌的品牌它的内部，
它内部肯定也是要有，
讲一个这个叫做品牌蓄势的逻辑，
它要把这些产品的基因它把它统一的归起来，
就是你以后提到胃牌，
胃牌等于什么，
这毕竟是创始人老板的名字命名的牌子，
对吧,
你不能光是说啊豪华豪华，
豪华是一个很犯的概念，
就是具体的大家为它买单，
能不能用一句话来总结，
我为什么要为胃牌去买单，
这个就非常的关键，
所以它要把它品牌基因品牌蓄势，
要统一起来，
那么在这样那个大背景下，
它出一个叫胃牌高山7SUV，
所以以上这些就是相当于我个人的一些分析，
也算是我个人的一些猜测，推测，
不代表任何的官方立场，
也是欢迎大家来进行讨论啊，
那么最后我们来聊一聊高山7SUV到底值不值得买啊，
其实在我看来中大型MPV，
它是属于偏奢侈的消费，
怎么理解呢？
就是你看，
首先你打算买一台中大型MPV，
无论是G28，
塞纳这种传统的，
还是说像藤氏第九，
难通梦想家，
还是我们今天聊的高山7、高山8、高山9，
就你的预算要准备多少万？
你要准备多少钱？
你怎么这也得30万上下吧？
你哪怕就是高山7，
稍微入美年的价格也得是25万上下，
好，那么25万到35万吧，
在这个区间，
你要知道有很多家庭也许它能掏得出30来万去买一台车，
但是真的有30万上下的预算，
绝大多数的家庭它的第一反应是买什么车？
如果他们之前没有开过BPA，
那我相信像这种家庭有30来万的预算，
它的第一反应就是想成为BPA的车主，
买奔驰，买宝马，买奥迪，
那么如果说这个家庭它本身就已经是拥有过BPA了，
开过好车的，
那么它现在30万左右的预算买什么车？
新能源SUV，
或者是新能源轿车，
因为这个选择的余地更大，
而且这种车型它是相当于中规中矩，
不管是从颜值配置，
还是说空间大小实用性，
都是OK的，
它完全没有必要说我得去选一个MPV，
你不管是从操控性时尚感还是各方面，
那肯定是SUV跟轿车的选择面更广，
那么你想一想，
什么人它最终会把目光是落在新能源MPV的车型上呢？
只有一种人，
就是它原本就需要一台MPV，
它就需要MPV，
它是奔着MPV去的，
只不过现在它发现，
在MPV的领域里面，
大家好像都不怎么去选择游车了，
都开始选择新能源了，
再去看一看新能源的这个选择，
现在好像也比以前要多很多了，
原来没什么可选的嘛，
要么就腾示第九，没了，
那现在有那么多的一些车型可以选，
那么有了很多的选择余地，
我就开始去横向对比了，
我去比一下大小空间价格，
造型颜值，
还有各方面的一些所谓的智能化的技术，
哪家更好一点，
去体验一下，是不是？
那么现在，
它恰巧在30代万的区间里面，
那么遇到了这几款车型，
它盘一盘自己的预算，
再去试一试这个车的驾乘感受，
那么它最终就知道自己要选什么车了，
所以它是先想好了车型是MPV，
然后再去根据这个MPV的车型，
它的指导价去定下我的预算是多还是少，
我身边已经无数多这样的案例了，
家里面两台车，
都是豪华品牌，
那么最终它要卖掉其中一辆，
去换一辆新灯原，
那么它们家里面就讨论来讨论去，
觉得说这辆车可能我平时开的也不多，
平时反正也有一辆油车可以开，
那么这辆车子我就把它定成MPV车型，
首先就是一定是要买个MPV车型，
然后呢看来看去最后发现，
我MPV车型我买一个新灯原，
我平时哈诺娜这个车子去逮捕，
它原本其实就想把这个车当成一个备用车，
结果可能反而这辆车子回来之后，
成了家里面的人都想开的一辆车，
因为那辆车子就比较他们家另外一辆油车，
是一辆比较多宝马X3也好，
奔驰E也好，
虽然说这个车子的大小体量，
它没有这辆MPV那么大，
但是那辆车它毕竟是烧油的，
它出门的成本是比这辆用电的MPV要高，
所以大家觉得说那我不如开这个MPV，
如果车位上还有一个充电桩往上一充电，
那多爽啊，对吧，
你平时你本管是续航100、200还是300、400，
反正我开出去几十公里，
我回来之后给它充满，不就行了嘛，
所以MPV对他们来讲，
它其实就是一辆电车，
虽然是一个混动车型，
但是他们平时就当个电车来开，
反而开起来很舒服，
而智能化程度也比力量油车要高很多，
所以原因很简单，
就是一方面这一部分人他本身拥有过豪华品牌，
他已经去妹了，
他开始更关注这个产品的产品力，
那么另外一方面他也开始回归家庭，
很多人像我身边有一些，
就是以前年轻的时候经常换车的嘛，
那么现在年龄大一些了，
有了孩子了，
甚至有了二娃，
有的家里面还有三娃的，
对吧,
像我们朗老师，
朗老师对吧，
在浙江安吉就是三娃，
是不是，
他就是喜欢大车，
为什么他一出门人就多，
他就喜欢大车，
他不仅仅是要大的SUV，
他也喜欢大的MPV，
只不过到今天为止，
我忽悠他还没有忽悠的动，
就是我想让他买大的MPV，
他还是想要操控性更好一点，
他也是对于颜值也有自己的需求的人，
他买的车都是比较骚弃的一些车，
所以他就要大一点的SUV车型，
但我相信他早晚有一天一定是会去换一辆，
这个中大型的MPV的，
所以换MPV的人，
我觉得还有一点就是，
基本上当你去换到一辆，
特别是像新灯源的MPV的时候，
你后面就不怎么去换车了，
所以我也能猜得到朗老师为什么一直不换MPV，
他也能看得到，
MPV千万不要轻易去买，
就是你买了MPV很有可能，
就是你人生换车的终点了，
最后一辆，
就是你到后面就不想换了，
因为MPV基本上什么事情都能干，
就是配置也全，功能也全，空间也全，
其实现在的新灯源的MPV动力也不差，
是不是，
所以你到后面换其他车有什么意思呢，
所然无畏，
他把你的星星已经给磨眉了，
那么还有一个，
我曾经节目里面也是反复提到，
就是我的小区是机械车位，
它的停车的车厂是不能超过5米2的，
但是很多的一些MPV车型，
它因为只有一个尺寸，
它只不过是根据它的配置来分不同的层级，
那么这一个尺寸只要是超过5米2，
那相当于就是这个MPV车型，
我即使想买，
我也可能会很纠结，
那我们家邻居，
它其实就买了一辆，
那么车厂超过5米2的MPV，
它停不了怎么办呢，
它只能是停到对面商场的停车厂，
去办包业，
包年包业，
那么它要用的时候，
它就得走到马路对面的商场停车厂去取车，
他们家肯定还有另外一辆带步车嘛，
那么就停在我们楼洞下面的正常的停车位上面，
那就有点麻烦了嘛，对不对，
好，那么现在它高山系列是分成三种不同的尺寸，
那么高山7它是5米出头一点点，
再到高山8是接近5米3，
再到高山9是超过5米4，
哎，那么如果说我真的我要想买个MPV，
我觉得说MPV平时带个步也没什么问题，
对吧，日常出行的话，
我当四座，我老婆孩子坐在二排也挺舒服的，
ok，那我可以选择高山7，
高山8我停不了，
因为它已经是接近5米3的车场了，
高山9更不用想了，
超过5米4了嘛，
我也不需要那么大的车，
哎，那我买个高山7，
5米出点头，
它至少就是我们家楼下的机械车位是能停得进去的，
你别小看这一点，
这一点能直接决定我到底是买MPV，
还是不买MPV，
所以我之前连买MPV的面头我都没有，
那有人肯定要讲了，
5米出头的MPV也有啊，
就是不超过5米2，
你可以去看一看库斯图啊，
你说我，
本身对MPV我就不感兴趣，
然后我再去为了去买一个小一点的MPV，
去买一个存在感，
存量很低的像库斯图这种车型，
我图啥呢，
你图啥呢，
对吧,
你高山哪怕就有一天，
它能冲到比方说MPV销量庞庙网第一名，
它整个体量在，
对吧,
它整个的这个产品的认可度也高，
品牌知名度也出去了，
这个时候我绕了一圈，
我发现行政员的车型里面，
好比说二十多万三十万左右，
功能配置质价至仓什么都有，
然后车潮呢也没超过5米2，
我想了想说，
哎,
也许这个车子合适啊，
对吧,
我如果陪伴老婆孩子的时间越来越多，
我只要是周末，
我就带他们去游山玩水，
哎,
我觉得行啊，
没问题啊，
买一辆这个车子MPV去开一开，
回归家庭，
没啥冒兵啊，
所以它是完全根据自己的需求来去订的，
只不过它根据不同的，
这个车型的大小，
来去定义产品，
这个玩法之前没有，
跟以前不一样，
那么这样一来的话，
它相当于它的客户群体，
又拓展了一圈，
甚至是两圈嘛，
对不对，
那么有些人讲说，
这个高山七跟高山八有多大的区别呢，
就是这个高山八，
它其实你仔细看啊，
它的整个的车身的这个，
设计的比例是比较协调的，
但是高山七有些人觉得，
它的车尾这一部分，
收的有点过早，
收的有点过紧，
这比例有一点点不太协调，
不够像高山八、高山九那么舒展，
更有气场，
那这个我其实是比较认可的，
虽然有些人说这个车头比较老气，
这个我倒不太认可，
我觉得MPV车子都差不多，
都不是特别的好看，
那车头长的其实，
我觉得都有点这种腰分撕裂的感觉，
但是你要说它的这个，
侧面的这个比例，
有点在高山七上不太协调，
这个我认可，
确实车尾，
就是车尾部收的会相对来讲比较早，
比较紧一点，
到了高山八会更加好一点，
到了高山九就更舒展了嘛，
但是因为它的价位不一样，
你不能因为仅仅是个造型，
你就选择高山八或者高山九，
但是你但凡，
你比方说高山七跟高山八，
就差个两万来块钱嘛，
你但凡预算是够的话，
那么大多数人是选择高山八，
所以高山八也是整个的，
销量里面的一个担当，
它卖的也是最好的一个版本，
三十万九千八对吧，
跟高山七二十万，
就是二十八万五千八，
差了两万四千块钱嘛，
所以我跟你讲，
其实有的时候，
你不用去谈什么配置的差异，
驾驶和乘坐的差异，
你光是站在车子的侧面，
你盯着这两台车子去看个十分钟，
你就完全知道你到底是要买高山七还是高山八了，
你甚至跟着差不差两万块钱，
两万多块钱都没有任何关系，
你盯上个十分钟，
你光是从颜值层面上来讲，
你就已经非常清晰的知道要选谁，
那么至于说，
高山七SUV这个车到底适合什么人买，
我觉得还是看你的使用的环境，
你要去试这个车，
你要去开这个车，
你要知道抬高了三公分之后，
这个车坐上去，
那种就是相对比较高重心的感觉，
你喜欢还是不喜欢，
你再去开一开，
普通版本的高山七是什么感觉，
包括高山八你也可以开一开，
你要感受一下这种高重心的坐姿，
这种开大车的体量感，
虽然说它没有那种很明显的这种大车的感觉，
我们知道大车有的时候开起来，
就像开轮船一样嘛，
它不够紧质，
但是它这个车本身是底盘键做了加强，
用了专属的复原簧，
那么它的整体的调教方向就是减少车内的起伏，
要稳住它的一些姿态，
在你去稍微激烈点驾驶的时候，
它不让这个车会有一种就是抚养很明显，
侧行很明显，
有一种抬高敲的感觉，
虽然这么讲，
但是我建议你还是要认真评估一下自己的用车环境，
怎么说呢，
就是你如果是一个比方说民宿的小老板，
你经常是要从乡村到城区两边跑，
或者说你是个录音爱好者，
你只要是一放假，
你只要是一到周末，
你就开着车子，
你去一些乡村小道，
你去玩，
你去露营，
或者说你是一些工地的老板，
经常要跑山路，
要走一些烂路，
石子路，
非出发路面，
好,
那我觉得如果是高山七跟高山七SUV，
那你是优先选择高山七SUV，
那并不是说这个车一定能越野，
而是说，
它至少相对的通过性会更好一些，
遇到一些勾勾侃侃，
遇到一些这种什么石子路，
石滑路面，
你最起码你心理上安全感，
会更强一点，
但如果说你家里面有老人孩子，
经常跟你一起出门，
而且你经常是在市区高速路上来回跑，
你80%-90%的路都是市区路跟高速路，
对吧,
像司机带着老板，
从豪宅到CBD，
从CBD到酒店停车场，
从酒店停车场再到机场，
高铁站这种，
一年到头，
你的轮胎里面都没有卡过小石子，
你的悬挂都没压过一个坑，
那你告诉我，
你买高山七SUV干啥呢？
你要那么高的离地间隙干什么呢？
没必要啊，
对不对，低门槛，
你让你们家老人孩子每次上车的时候，
都能方便一点，
这个才是更需要啊，
所以你一定要想清楚，
你自己的需求点是什么，
而不是说，
什么车子新上市，
我就追新去买，
不是个概念，
那么以上呢，
就是关于今天，
我之前试驾高山七SUV的一些想法，
我没有去过多的，
讲解这个产品具体的配置，
那个配置之间的一些区别点，
什么二三排共轨啦，
什么三排放倒，
二排放倒，
什么车那些配置，
我没讲那么多，
你要如果想看这些的话，
我还有长视频，
你可以在比利比利啊，
去搜摆设全说，
或者是在小红书啊，
抖音啊，
视频号啊，
去搜索三刀砍车，
那么都更新了我这个视频，
就是高山的这个评测，
然后高山七SUV，
大家可以去，
细细的评一下，
这个视频将近20分钟，
我关于车内的一些配置的一些体验，
讲得非常的清楚，
以后呢，
我觉得这样挺好的，
在这个我们的音频节目里面，
我来分析分析一些，
我对于它的品牌策略，
营销方式，
这个车适合什么人，
我可以把它展开来，
讲得更透彻一些，
然后在我们的试驾视频里面呢，
就是我看到了什么，
用到了什么，
我体验到了什么，
我在视频当中，
给它展现出来，
我觉得挺好的，
配合起来做，
对吧,
大家如果想关注一款车，
你可以通过视频和音频，
联合起来，
取伤不断，
把它还原成一个
完整的我的，
这种试驾体验，
希望对你将来买车，
能够有所帮助，
好，那么以上就是，
本期节目的主要内容，
下面是留言互动环节，
喜马拉雅小宇宙的庭友，
听到这儿，
如果没有订阅的话，
可以点击一下订阅，
每周三，
每周六更新，
都会有提醒，
那么喜马拉雅的庭友呢，
在播放页面的下方，
可以投送免费的月票，
对于我曝光，
会很有帮助，
谢谢大家，
那么评论区呢，
每期会抽三位，
会进行一个互动，
那么赠送的呢，
是由人言计提供的，
苹果翠两包，
好的,
下面是，
上期节目呢，
我们聊的是比亚迪的大堂，
这个车呢，
我看,
在网上口碑还挺好的，
而且呢，
很多人对这车，
还挺感兴趣的，
这年头，
大家这个换车，
是越换，
价格越贵了，
我看到有一位庭友，
他的名字叫做，
我是阿德，
得不到的爸爸，
这个名字，
起的有点意思，
这个阿德是谁，
他说,
糟糕,
你好,
听你节目很久了，
我第一次留言，
平时呢，
是用播客来听，
为了留言，
那个呢，
是不太好留言的，
所以有些人，
为了想留言跟我互动，
都会去，
重新再下载，
西马拉雅，
或者是小雨这儿，
非常感谢大家，
他说,
今天聊的这个主题呢，
很吸引我，
因为最近，
想买三排，
大型SUV,
就是三排做的，
他说我有个困惑，
想跟你探讨一下，
我呢,
不喜欢旅行，
但是我喜欢大车，
因为我感觉大就是美，
但是呢，
我的预算不高，
我跟你一样，
是被房地产给坑了，
哎,
你看你这话说的，
在下行的过程当中，
每个人，
资产稍微的蒸发掉一点，
都是很正常的事情，
啊,
好吧,
就是我确实是被坑了，
我们都被坑了，
他说呢，
我是买车，
是偏向于使用，
我不需要支架，
也不需要主动选价，
我更不需要空穴，
这些东西，
我觉得他们的使用寿命，
呃,
不会很长，
我将来可能维修的，
这个成本，
我承担不起，
我原来看的是，
一派008,
啊,
五米以上的车，
三排做，
那么,
我看你演他的销量，
我就觉得，
这么低的销量，
这么差，
我就不敢下手啊，
同时呢，
也注意到了华晋S，
配置呢，
也符合要求，
也是15万左右，
啊,
我不想花六千块钱，
去开通什么支架，
也不影响我，
用自动驳车，
但是我不敢下手的原因，
也是我感觉，
这个车销量，
也不咋低啊，
所以我想知道为什么，
大家现在，
都这么有钱了吗，
都愿意去支付，
这个品牌的一家了吗，
但是我也相信，
眼睛是血量的，
大家既然选择，
那些更贵的车型，
肯定是有他们的原因，
那这些车，
虽然便宜，
大家不买，
也有大家的原因，
说三刀能不能解释一下，
我觉得这个叫，
阿德得不到的爸爸，
他这个问题，
非常的真实啊，
那么有些兄弟们，
预算不是特别的高，
像他这样，
那又想开，
像这样的一种，
三排做的，
六座七座的大车，
那么大家也会去想，
这只车，
一排008,
华晋S,
这些车，
价比无敌的高啊，
那华晋我还没拍啊，
这个一排008，
我是拍过的，
我当时开到这个车的时候，
我第一感觉也是，
我的天，
这么大个车子，
定价才十几万，
二十万不到，
那么大家其实买大车，
你觉得怕的是什么，
你想这个问题点，
大家其实怕的是踩坑，
是吧,
便宜是便宜，
尺寸配置，
实用性各方面，
看的也很香，
但是问题在于，
这类车，
缺的不是参数，
而是信任感，
十五万多，
买一辆五米多的，
这样的一个，
三排多的大的SUV，
消费者第一反应是赚到了吗，
其实不一定，
他不一定感觉是赚到了，
他可能会想，
看上去还行啊，
看上去还行，
用的时间久了之后，
这么便宜的车，
他的品控怎么样啊，
他的品控，
他后期会不会，
我要花更多的钱，
去修他，
今天不是这里想，
就是那里想，
不是这里一个小零件坏，
就是那里一个小零件坏，
他的品牌能不能撑得住啊，
他会不会在看不见的地方，
偷工减料啊，
只不过用几块大屏幕，
忽悠忽悠我呀，
是吧,
包括他的售后，
整体的品质，
能不能撑得住啊，
他本身卖车，
也不挣钱了，
那么他今后，
售后的这个服务质量，
还能不能有保证啊，
那这个产品，
他的保质率怎么样啊，
将来当二手车，
还有没有人能够接盘，
愿意去买我的车，
我买的是便宜啊，
那我卖的时候，
是不是更便宜呢，
尤其像这种，
三排做的SUV，
他往往是家里的主力车型，
所以有些人，
他令愿多花个几万块钱啊，
去买那些品牌的新工度，
更高的，
他更认可的一些车型，
而且呢，
他默认这些车型，
不管是使用成本也好，
还是说将来的这个，
售后的服务体验也好，
他是默认会比这些，
小众一点的品牌，
会更好一点，
而且你要知道，
很多人，
他既然选择买这种，
车长超过5米，
甚至超过5米，
15米2的车，
他本身的预算，
甚至是30多万，
所以他根本就没有必要去看那些，
15、6万、20万不到的，
这种车型，
所以他就是，
我没有这个预算，
我就不看这个车，
而你是属于，
我现在想买这样一个级别的车，
我去针对性的找，
有没有这个预算范围内的，
15到20万的，
所以你是这样一类的，
消费者，
也不能说，
不好,
只能说，
你这个疑问，
肯定是大家都有的，
但是呢，
这种车型，
就只能讲是赌一把了，
我也不知道他的长期耐用心，
因为像你刚刚说的，
这两款车，
都是上市时间不是很久的，
所以不是群众不实货，
而是大多数人，
买车买的不是配置表，
是确定性，
就是市场上市，
已经很久的车型，
大家已经对他的品控，
品质,
认证过之后，
陆陆续续的销量，
就保持在，
稳定,
好比说一个月一万台，
或者是一个月八千台，
这样的一个级别，
所以,
越是长期持有的车型，
就越不太能接受小众车，
但是如果说，
我也不担心，
小毛小病，
我正常修，
CS店就开在我们家对面，
我也不担心，
CS店将来就倒掉，
倒了之后，
可能其他地方，
会再建一家，
你如果心，
很大,
放得也很宽，
预算确实也就那么多，
客观条件也不允许，
去选择，
其他的车型，
那么像这种，
销量比较小的车，
那你就买就买呗，
对吧,
但是你要，
把这些风险点，
都考虑进去，
好吧,
那么下面一位，
听有叫做，
他说,
其实影响大唐，
包括他后续，
旗舰车型，
在闪冲功能的这些车，
销量的，
一个关键点是什么，
就是高速服务区的，
充电桩的，
扑射进度，
高端车的消费者，
更在意体验的完整度，
你让他什么都，
将就一下，
高速上没有充电桩，
没有闪冲桩，
没关系，
你下了高速再去充，
不行的，
高端的消费人群，
他讲究的是习惯，
他习惯了，
在这种服务区里面，
能够体验到闪冲，
那么这样一来的话，
他也会跟旁边的人，
去推荐，
对不对，
那高端的这个社群，
慢慢的这个口碑，
影响力就起来了，
另外就是，
想要做高端，
高价值的产品，
就是高附加值的产品，
细节的打磨，
确实很重要，
尤其是内饰，
虽然说这两年，
比亚迪的内饰，
也进步不小，
包括撕掉的搭配，
材料的材质搭配，
那么各种功能界的，
开磨的一体性都还行，
但是呢，
其实它可以再精细一点，
用料可以再狭一点血本，
再打磨打磨，
对于高端车型来讲，
如果还是在某些方面，
想要嗑嗑嗑嗑的，
那么如果输在这一方面的话，
其实是挺可惜的，
因为这一方面，
想优化起来很简单，
只要你肯下去本，
你肯下去的性，
所以这一点，
其实是可以多学一学未来，
这是这一位叫做，
鲁鱼斯ZCY的留言，
其实我很认可，
我非常认可，
这两点都很关键，
一个就是高速服务区的，
闪冲桩的铺设的进度，
我的天哪，
如果全中国的高速服务区，
能够说，
大量的去铺设这个闪冲桩，
那是非常爽，
真的非常爽，
我主要是没时间跑长途，
如果我有时间跑长途，
经常跑的话，
那我可能，
如果你比较说，
全中国的服务区，
百分之不要多，
你百分之六十以上，
你如果都有闪冲桩的话，
那我可能，
我也会优先去考虑，
去买一辆比阿迪的，
带闪冲功能的车，
那很爽，
真的很爽，
我根本都不用在乎他的，
续航里程有多少，
上了高速找几个，
我就提前规划好嘛，
我就看看这一路上，
一共有多少个服务区，
其中哪些服务区有闪冲桩，
那很爽啊，
进去几分钟就充满了，
我也不用充满，
我充到个百分之七八十，
我基本上就到了，
甚至七八十都不需要，
往往跑高速，
你算一笔上嘛，
你中间充一次还是充两次，
中间其实就差那么一两百公里，
你其实就是，
蓄个一两百公里的雪，
就完全够了嘛，
一两百公里对于闪冲桩来讲，
那真的是，
太快了真的是，
下面一位听友，
叫做服务区上的多喜乐，
他说,
我的骑郡，
是2019年1月份的车，
马上快八年的车灵了，
已经七年多了嘛，
那么现在我的工作地点有变化，
上下班来回得要120公里，
最近比阿迪出了二代刀片电池，
还有闪冲，
这就让我萌生了换车的想法，
但是也有人跟我说，
其实新能源车并不省钱，
它平时用下来省，
但是等到你卖的时候，
你其实算一算，
整个生命周期不省钱，
这个我其实在那个。
八年斩杀线的互动问题里面，
也讲得很清楚了，
包括我也有视频，
也是在各大平台流量还可以，
也是讲，
新能源车到底省不省钱这件事情，
你要感兴趣，
可以去搜一搜看一看，
他说,
就拿大堂来讲，
三吨多的车重，
但是轮胎的消耗成本，
就非常的大，
其实我对大堂很感兴趣，
我也看过时车，
我就想问一问三刀，
要不要换车，
如果是换的话，
应该是选哪个版本，
其实一句话，
我就可以总结你这样的一个问题，
你连轮胎的消耗成本，
都很担心的，
这样一个用户，
那我是强烈不建议你去换车的，
就说明什么，
说明你的收入和你的存款，
还没有到换车的时候，
习近难道不能开吗，
它只是老了一点，
它并不是不能开啊，
对不对，
如果你的预算，
你的存款，
你去换一辆，
像比亚迪大堂这种车，
二十来万，
你一点压力都没有，
什么换轮胎，
你换就换呗，
轮胎又怎样啊，
一条轮胎一千多，
四条轮胎五六千块钱，
换呗,
你到了这个时间点，
你该换就换嘛，
是不是，保养维修啊，
包括这个车辆，
日常的一些使用成本，
每一年的保险，
其实也不便宜，
你根本就没有任何压力，
那这个车子，
我觉得你换起来很轻松，
但是我目前挺想，
我感觉不是这样子的，
我觉得你，
车还没买，
你就开始考虑到说，
这个轮胎的消耗量很大，
成本很高，
那就说明你肯定是预算不足嘛，
预算不足，
我觉得你就换一换，
等到你的这个资金池，
沉淀的更多一点，
然后你的工作地点是刚换，
我不知道是公司刚换，
还是怎样，
等到你的工作更稳定一些，
然后家里整体来讲，
你已经能够预计到，
三年五年内，
没有大的开销，
你账上也没有太多的，
就是,
那种负债，
你没有这种用杠杆，
去买房啊，
或者是怎样，
那么在保证你，
正常的这个家庭质量，
不会有所变化，
保证你的资金流水，
你的现金流，
不会出现一些，
这个问题点的时候，
你在掏出这么一些钱，
去买一个比亚迪的大堂，
我觉得就没有任何问题，
那那个时候，
你在买，
你就根本不会去问这样的问题啊，
你说啊，
换个轮胎成本高，
你不会这么问，
好吧,
所以呢，
我觉得大家，
像现在这个年代去换车，
一定要慎重，
硬件也在换，
软件也在升级，
对吧,
然后各种各样那些，
新的营销名词，
确实很刺激大家，
但是大家一定要量入为初啊，
一定要，
守得住寂寞，
经得住诱惑，
啊,
这个口袋里面的钱，
那仨瓜俩澡的，
就是什么人都在惦记着，
现在都是让你去消费，
消费，拼命的刺激你消费，
啊,
如果这个时候，
你再不能，
你再不能花两封金。
○○○○○○Ē Œ Expedition。
来一次吗，
我没架飞四艘布。
我到问问题就可以了。
говорит Sciss Celebrity 。
利息区，
那都是我们来的原因，
那后悔已经来不及了 是吧？
好的 那么以上就是本期节目所有的内容感到收听。
那么留言互动的听有。
可以获得由人言计提供的苹果翠两包。
那么可以联系我们的盾牌。
盾牌的微信46415254。
想跟我单独联系也可以联系这个微信。
46415254。
那么更多的原创内容。
大家可以在bdbd搜索摆车全书。
也可以在抖音视频号小红书快手。
去搜索三刀砍车
还有我的个人微博叫摆车全书三刀。
每天都有更新
那么以及我们的公众号摆车全书。
大家也可以关注一下。
好的 今天这期节目就到这里。
我们下期接着聊 拜拜。